on pourra rester en stationnaire aessus
avis il ils sont plus dans l'her ils
sont plus dans
le je crois qu' passer laisser passer ça
fera un plan qui rentre et qui sort
sinon on va tout le temps en altitude
altitude
fantastique ah ils ont
plus quoi over
let dans l'eau qui fait il y en a qui
fait vachement d'eau là celui que tu
vois CELI qui à gauche l'extrême gauche
fa beaucoup d'eau il est super il marche
dans l'eau il est
cétait magnifique
ça
c'est fini c'est sublime regard les tu
verrais l'eau qu' avait ça GIC mon pas
tu verras les
photos c'est be tu V laisser sortir pere
du champ moment
donnéme il vrouver il v retrouver les
autres il v retrouver les autres il
retrouve les autres voilà tu vas tu vas
devant eux tuas un gros TR tu retrouves
troupeau d'éléphant devant eux voilà
accompagne un petit peu accompagne
jusqu'
troupeau accompagner vas-y
là faut que je le
revienne att ah
mer ok let's
go le mouvement de caméra tu crois qu'il
est fait
euh